back in 2013 I produced one of the
strangest videos on YouTube a video
about Arabic in Japanese with English
subtitles and me teaching an Arabic
lesson to Japanese viewers at the end
lots of people were bewildered today I'm
going to try again hello everyone
welcome to the Lang focused Channel and
my name is Paul today's topic is the
Arabic language or a lot of the as it's
called in Arabic Arabic is the fifth
most widely spoken language in the world
with 293 million native speakers and 422
million speakers in total it's an
official language in 26 countries that
doesn't mean it's the majority language
in all of those countries but it's one
of the official languages it is also one
of the six official languages of the
United Nations and as the language of
the Quran the holy book of Islam it is
also the liturgical language of 1.7
billion Muslims around the world most of
those people don't speak Arabic but many
have some knowledge of Arabic for
reading and for reciting prayers and
religious study speaking about Arabic
can be confusing because there are many
different varieties of the language
one of the main varieties is the
classical Arabic of the Quran this is
considered by many to be the most
perfect form of Arabic and some say it's
the only true Arabic because it was the
language in which God revealed the Quran
to Muhammad then there's modern Standard
Arabic which is the form of Arabic used
as an official language today it's the
modern form of literary Arabic which was
based on the classical Arabic of the
Quran but with some adaptations and a
greatly expanded vocabulary to make it
more suitable for modern times it's not
exactly the same as classical Arabic but
both of them are referred to by Arabs as
emphasis on meaning eloquent speech
modern Standard Arabic is the language
of books media education and formal
situations but not as the language of
everyday speech for everyday speech
Arabic speakers use their local dialects
or I'm me which can differ quite
significantly from country to country
and even from one place to another
within a single country Arabic is a
Semitic language Arabic and other
Semitic languages like Hebrew
Aramaic and Phoenician all developed
from the same proto Semitic language
Arabic forms one branch of central
Semitic while another branch of central
Semitic includes Hebrew Aramaic and
Phoenicians old Arabic numerous Semitic
languages related to Arabic were spoken
in Arabia between the 13th and 10th
century CE II but they don't have
features that would classify them as
Arabic the earliest evidence of people
referred to as Arab is in an Assyrian
inscription from the eighth century BCE
what it just mentions the Arabs it
doesn't give any examples of their
language from the 6th century BCE to the
4th century CE e we have inscriptions
showing evidence of an early form of
Arabic some of those inscriptions are
written in that early form of Arabic and
others are written in Aramaic but show
some influence from Arabic those
inscriptions consist mostly of proper
names so they don't give us an awful lot
of information about what the language
was like the earliest inscription that
is unmistakably Arabic is from the 1st
century BCE and was found that enough
that it's an Aramaic inscription but it
contains three lines of Arabic another
inscription was discovered at M numata
120 kilometers southeast of Damascus
dating back to 329 C II the language of
this inscription is nearly identical to
classical Arabic as we know it even
though these inscriptions are
unmistakably written in Arabic they are
not written in the Arabic script but
rather the Nabataean script which
derived from the aramaic script but
there are also inscriptions from the 4th
and 5th century CE II that are written
in a script that's more like Arabic it's
generally thought that the Arabic script
developed from the Nabataean script and
these inscriptions might be written in a
script that's somewhere between those 2
classical Arabic before the beginning of
Islam there were numerous dialects of
Arabic spoken around the peninsula but
there was also a common literary
language used among the different tribes
for poetry a coin a which was a
compromise between the various dialects
the pieces of poetry written in this
literary Koine are the earliest examples
of classical Arabic the Quran was
written in the 7th century when Muslims
believe that the Quran was revealed to
Muhammad by the angel Gabriel and then
it was written down over a 23-year
period at the time the Quran was written
were seven dialects of classical Arabic
so Quran was written in all of them but
the Quraysh e-version
became the standard upon which the text
of today's Quran is based the
differences are in pronunciation not in
vocabulary or grammar the Arabic of the
Quran is similar to that of the
pre-islamic classical Arabic poetry but
not exactly beginning during the life of
Muhammad and continuing into the eighth
century the Islamic conquests spread the
Arabic language into new faraway lands
after the Islamic conquests there was an
important need to standardize the
language because vast numbers of people
were beginning to speak it the script
was made more practical new vocabulary
was created and the grammar and style of
prose was standardized neo Arabic and
middle Arabic while classical Arabic was
being standardized as a written language
local dialects of Arabic also emerged in
the cities of the Arab Empire these
dialects did not descend directly from
classical Arabic but rather from
pre-islamic Arabic dialects or from a
single Arabic Koine which was the common
language of conquering Arab armies these
new dialects were also influenced by the
original languages of areas that were
conquered the dialects of the Levant and
Mesopotamia were influenced by Aramaic
the dialects of the Maghreb were
influenced by Berber the dialects of
Egypt were influenced by Coptic and so
on the early centuries of the newly
emerging dialects are referred to as neo
Arabic even though classical Arabic was
standardised
not everybody could write it perfectly
writing that contains features of both
classical Arabic and neo Arabic or
dialects is referred to as Middle Arabic
middle doesn't refer to a time period
but rather these texts were somewhere in
the middle between classical and
colloquial modern Arabic over the
centuries the neo Arabic dialect
continued to evolve into the modern
colloquial dialects of today but
literary Arabic remains relatively
constant because the Arabic of the Quran
was always seen as the ideal Arabic to
imitate and this probably had a
conservative effect on the dialects
limiting them from changing too much
after Napoleon entered Egypt in 1798 the
Arab world entered a period of greater
contact with the West the influx of new
Western concepts required the Arabic
language to be updated in the early 20th
century regional academies of the
arabic-language began a process of
language reform focused mainly on
expanding and updating the languages
vocabulary these updates culminated in
what is now known as modern Standard
Arabic diglossia Arabic is well known
for its state of diglossia Arabic
speakers used two distinctly different
forms of the language in parallel for
different purposes modern Standard
Arabic is not learned by anyone as a
native language but it's used in reading
and writing in media on children's TV
shows and in formal speeches while the
colloquial dialects are used almost
universally for daily conversation as I
mentioned before there's quite a lot of
variation amongst Arabic dialects how
well two speakers understand each other
depends on the geographic distance of
their dialects as well as exposure many
Arabic speakers have told me that
speakers of the Middle Eastern dialects
really have no trouble understanding
each other and that the main trouble
comes in understanding the Maghrebi
dialect especially Moroccan but these
days with the spread of cable TV and the
internet people are being exposed to a
wider range of dialects on a more
regular basis which helps people
understand different dialects more and
of course there's also alpha ska modern
Standard Arabic when speakers of
significantly different dialects
communicate with each other they can
switch to modern Standard Arabic or they
can adjust their speech to make it more
formal and literary and similar to
modern Standard Arabic but not exactly
another common way for native speakers
to bridge the dialect gap is to use
something called the white dialect which
is a more formal version of dialectal
speech that uses features that are
common to most of the different dialects
but it leaves out features that are
limited to specific dialects this is
essentially a modern Arabic coin a
sowhat's Arabic like let's take a look
at some features of Arabic focusing on
modern Standard Arabic the script the
Arabic script is written from right to
left and consists of letters that
imitate handwriting most letters join to
the letter that comes after them however
a few letters remain disjoint the
letters that join have two forms one
short form at the beginning or in the
middle of words and another long form at
the end of words or when the letter is
by itself the Arabic script is an abjad
meaning that each letter represents a
consonant and that short vowels are not
really
and that long vowels and diphthongs can
be ambiguous how can we read Arabic
without vowels well can you read this
here the short vowels are not written
and the others seem somewhat incomplete
but we have a hint about what the vowels
are this is kind of like reading Arabic
but Arabic has more predictable vowel
patterns than English so it's easier to
guess also Arabic can be written with
hodduk ad which are extra diacritic
markings that indicate the short vowel
sounds these are generally only used in
texts that are really important to
pronounce perfectly like the Quran or
poetry or children's materials phonology
Arabic has a number of consonant sounds
which are surprising or challenging for
speakers of many other languages for
example ha as in the word salines
meaning golf
then there's pause as in the word column
pen this is like a que but pronounced
further back in your throat then there's
the letter ha like in the word par
meaning
hot wine some say that this is similar
to the French R sound for example the
word orifice meaning room Arabic also
has a number of in Phatak consonants for
example there's scene which is like the
regular S sound in English but there is
also saab which is an emphatic s as in
the word fuzzy meaning small also notice
the sign in the middle to make this
sound you have to keep your tongue close
to the roof of your mouth if you want to
try it
position your mouth as though you are
going to say a K and hold that position
then make an S sound instead go ahead
try it
saw saw there are three other emphatic
consonants - an emphatic tall
dog and Zhou morphology Arabic words are
mostly constructed from three-letter
roots or sometimes for and these letters
are then inserted into templates
consisting of a fixed vowel pattern and
some structural continents if you know
the root letters you can identify the
core meaning of the word and if you know
the template you know what type of word
it is let's take the root ha ha
Jean which means to go out or to exit
and let's put it into this template we
get the word Maharaj which is the noun
meaning exit like a door you exit
through
to this template indicates a place where
the action of the route is done if we
use the route dala
kah lam which means to come in we get
led the hunt which means entrance if we
use the route cast that bear we get
elected meaning office these kinds of
recurring templates help you to know how
to pronounce words even when the short
vowels are not written if you see the
letter meme followed by three route
letters altogether with no long vowels
you can guess that the word is in this
template and pronounce it with too short
a vowels verbs in Arabic are part of the
same system of roots and templates the
templates tell us the 10th person gender
and number of the verb and the route
provides us the core meaning again let's
take the route ha ha
Jean and pop it into this template here
and we get hat azzam and we know what
this means
it's the past tense third person
masculine singular conjugation he exited
how does I mean Adam Edessa this means
he exited the school now put the root
into this template how let's do this
means I exited this suffix here
indicates past tense first person
singular are still me get elected this
means I exited the office if we put it
into this template yeah so it means he
exits this is the present tense template
yes what was only elected this means he
exits the office resumed means they exit
saya who's una manera negative this
means they will exit the office the
sentence is in the future tense to
change the present tense to the future
tense you simply add the suffix SAP to
the beginning of the present tense
template SAP is used for near future and
a separate particle sofa is used for the
more distant future Arabic has no other
verb tenses only past and present and
future which uses the present tense
conjugation this Semitic system of roots
and templates is really quite intuitive
once you get used to it and it's quite
ingenious if you ask me word order
modern Standard Arabic is a VSO language
by default as opposed to Arabic dialects
which are mainly SVO yet looser Roger
lavinia the
means the man is studying Arabic here's
the verb the subject and the object
these are the definite article al but
before certain letters the lam or the L
sound assimilates to the following
letter so al dajjal becomes our rajala
this is the basic word order but SVO is
also possible in a sentence with a
pronoun VSO is not possible for example
and a sofa a Druce al arabiya
this means I will study Arabic in the
future you can't say South a drisana Al
Arabiya
you can either say it with the pronoun
first or with no pronoun just sofa
drusilla Ravinia because the verb
conjugation tells us that this is the
first person singular so we don't need
the pronoun cases one aspect of Standard
Arabic is cases there are three cases in
Arabic nominative genitive and
accusative and nouns take special
endings to show their function in the
sentence let's take the word Khattab
which means book in nominative it's T
tableau in generative it's keypad be in
accusative it kitada al khattab we'll
Valdez ooh this means the excellent book
the noun key tab is in the nominative
and the adjective is also inflected to
agree with the noun and an upper
al-khattab and this means I am reading a
book here key tab is in the accusative
and it's indefinite the end sound at the
end here indicates that it's indefinite
what if' will get a B this means the
author of the book here key tab is in
the genitive case these case endings are
not used at the end of a sentence but
only when the word is followed by
something the form at the end of a
sentence without a case ending is called
the puzzle form these case endings are
often not used in modern Standard Arabic
they're generally only used in prepared
texts or prepared speeches two more
sentences - Louie all except this means
I usually don't work on Saturday
word-for-word it's usually no I work day
the Saturday that is the negation
particle used for the present tense
Armen is the verb for work and its root
is ein meme LEM and this is the first
person singular present tense
young and acept irani Dafa so together
they mean the day of Saturday yadava is
a construction of two nouns side by side
to show possession fun fact the word
Sabbath comes from the Hebrew word
shabbat which is related to this Arabic
word Sabbath Seth would say you're a
tienen victim this means I'll Drive my
car to the office word for word 'it's
will I Drive my car to the office
remember saw is added to the present
tense verb to form the future food
contains the verb off Wow
dal and this is the first person
singular present tense conjugation saya
Fe is the word saya with a possessive
suffix meaning my at the end and when a
suffix is added the letter hat becomes @
@ Allah is a preposition showing
direction the L here or the lamb is the
definite article l but the a sound or
the Aleph assimilates to the preceding
long a as you can see Arabic is a
fascinating language with lots of
interesting features from its script to
its phonology to its root and template
system it's a language that often seems
intimidating to learners but that's
partly because modern Standard Arabic
materials are aimed at reading and
writing and grammar rather than on
communication materials for learning
Arabic dialects tend to be more fun and
communicative the question that's asked
over and over and over is what form of
Arabic should I learn a dialect or
modern Standard Arabic in my opinion
it's important to learn some modern
Standard Arabic either before you start
to learn a dialect or at the same time
but if you know some modern Standard
Arabic it will help you to make sense of
different dialects that you encounter
and it will help you to understand
different registers of speech even when
people are speaking in their dialects
but if your main goal is communications
then I don't think it's necessary to
learn to speak modern Standard Arabic at
a high level and that brings me to the
question of the day two native speakers
of Arabic and to learners of Arabic
alike what do you think which form of
Arabic is the best to learn modern
Standard Arabic or a dialect leave your
answers in the comments down below be
sure to follow Lange focus on Facebook
Twitter or Instagram it's especially
important these days because weird thing
are happening with YouTube and nobody's
really sure what the future will bring
so it's good to have a way to be in
touch with you outside of YouTube so I
can let you know what's happening with
my videos and in a worst case scenario
where my videos will be if not on
YouTube so be sure to follow me on at
least one of those and I want to say
thanks again as usual to all of my
patreon supporters especially these
people right here on the screen for
they're very helpful monthly pledges
thank you for watching and have a nice
stay
[Music]